it's been raining since midnight
it's too dangerous to take the boat out
we fishermen have observed how the
weather has changed
the strong easterly winds that we see
right now
should have passed by now
the rainy season used to end in january
and february used to be one of the
driest months of the year
climate change has changed all that
fishermen have to be very attuned to the
weather
and notice every shift in deviation
colin serranina has four children two
have already left home
his wife jocelyn tells us they have
managed to raise a family
even if food that is fish has sometimes
been scarce
[Music]
and i'm very proud of that
my husband and i never went to school it
just wasn't possible
later in the morning the weather
improved
colin serranina soon caught two large
fish
he'll sell the red snapper
it weighs more than five kilos
on a good day he catches 15 kilos of
fish
the family always keeps a portion and
sells the rest to others in the
neighborhood
before the pandemic he used to sell to a
trader who supplied large markets
it was profitable but the markets are
closed for now
his neighbors can't pay those kind of
prices
jocelyn serenina does the bookkeeping
when they have money to spare she
deposits it with the savings club
[Music]
cannot savings club
the savings club is like a bank for us
we don't have a
most people in pilar live from fishing
there's not much else to do here
the local savings club was set up four
years ago
[Music]
an official from the municipality looks
after the money
the club has four hundred members the
deposits currently amount
to the equivalent of about eight and a
half thousand euros
we meet once a week
and that's when our members bring their
money
some deposit 20 pesos others 40
a few even 50.
20 pesos is a third of a euro it'll buy
you a bottle of water
and that's all some people can put aside
after a week's work
they would probably have even less were
it not for efforts to protect the
island's coastal waters
from overfishing in 2005 marine
protected areas were established
where no fishing is allowed and the fish
can breed in peace
in pilar volunteers patrol the coast
around the clock
this is their guard post
these protected areas have made a big
difference
fish stocks were dwindling
the german environment ministries
international climate initiative
is supporting the fishing community's
efforts to help themselves
suzanne cattaglio heads the
municipality's disaster relief unit
she helped set up the protected area
in pillar we experienced so many
changes that maybe
that's the cause by of climate change
like the sea level rise
extreme heat long drought
and heavy rainfall and the occurrence of
frequent occurrence of storms it's
evening
and the serenina family are preparing
supper
on the menu fish of course with
lemongrass
tomatoes and chili and rice
i boil some water
then i add the vegetables and then the
fish
the two daughters who still live at home
have been studying climate change at
school
they understand how it's affecting life
here
[Music]
it's a big problem for my father it
makes me really sad
it's so hot out there on the water and
then he might not even catch a single
fish
i feel sorry for him he works really
hard
but still sometimes comes home
empty-handed
the sereninas can only hope for good
weather and calm seas
life is tough and getting tougher on the
commodities
you